according to the Energy Information
Administration the United States is
about to run out of diesel fuel our
supply of diesel will be exhausted in
less than a month
well that mean exactly well currently
seven states are at quote alert level
four the entire Southeast is at code red
that means 72-hour notice is required
for all fuel deliveries in anticipation
of shortages the diesel shortage is a
symptom of a larger problem distillates
that would include jet fuel diesel fuel
heating oil or at their lowest recorded
levels in more than a decade so there
are a lot of reasons for this the
Biden's religious war against Russia is
the main one
but the effect on the country that's the
question tonight what will that mean if
we run out of these distillates in the
middle of winter Mike Taylor is the
owner of combined Energy Services he
joins us tonight Mike thanks so much for
coming on so
what will that look like exactly
well Tucker I'm hearing from our
suppliers that it seems like we're
walking a fine Tightrope on home heating
oil and Diesel Supply I can really only
speak to the Northeast they're telling
me that in reserves we're at 60 percent
of a five-year average all of our
heating oil in the Northeast most of it
comes out of the Philadelphia Market
Linden New Jersey good news is a
refinery in Paulsboro New Jersey is
coming back online producers I
understand 105 million barrels a day so
that's going to help the Northeast over
oil comes out of that region floats up
through the New York Harbor and that
supplies New England we've already seen
curtailments and shortages up on the
Hudson River terminals that was early
October our suppliers are really saying
it's a fine tightrope that if we have a
drastically cold winter could be trouble
could be trouble in supposedly the
richest most developed nation in the
world were afraid of winter
um so what would that mean for prices
for heating oil okay and Kerosene by the
way which a lot of poor people use in
their trailers what would that look like
in February
no question already we've seen the last
two years home heating oil is up over
three dollars and fifty cents a gallon
retail home heating oil in the Northeast
is over six dollars a gallon today
kerosene when we can get it is at seven
as we've spoken in the past mobile homes
use kerosene it's very hard to get right
now and it's going to be unaffordable
the climate change agenda in the
Northeast Tucker is what really what's
causing this of course across the
country demonization of fossil fuels but
in New York state New Jersey we're on
Fast Track to try to eliminate fossil
fuels with no Alternatives that anybody
can afford
too
it's definitely going to go up cord wood
pellet stoves but in 2030 New York state
is outlawing all fossil fuel uh meaning
natural gas propane gas heating oil all
appliances in your home New Jersey is
outlawing all large boilers starting in
2025. uh what they're saying is any
boiler 1 million BTUs are up which are
all your natural gas heating and oil
heating systems in New Jersey there's
over 8 300 of them have to convert to
electricity Tucker New Jersey has
already estimated it's going to cost
over 2 million dollars to convert each
one of these buildings and they've
admitted with an operating cost five to
six times using electricity over natural
gas the crash course we're on the
northeast is just undescribable well
that's just that's that's the definition
of insanity Mike Taylor I appreciate
your coming on tonight thank you
thanks for having me Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight